welcome back
so we're walking through this document
control for societal scale challenges
roadmap 2030 which is an IEEE control
system Society publication and now I'm
going to zoom in to chapter 2 which is
all about the societal drivers and
challenges that are essentially
motivating us to join together and to
work together to find control theory
Solutions okay this is one of the most
important chapters of this roadmap I
want to say it's about a third of the
entire document about 80 pages long and
so this really does set the stage for
what are the societal scale challenges
that motivate our next generally
generation uh kind of collaborative
Cooperative control Solutions okay so
this is where it's at again Link in the
description below download it read it
yourself this is going to be a very
topical very kind of shallow pick and
choose high level overview of this
chapter there is so much depth and
substance here that I can't cover in
this video so I highly encourage you to
read this yourself get inspired get
motivated uh you know and actually get
working on these problems
so some of the sections here we're going
to talk about climate change mitigation
and adaptation so climate change is an
issue that faces humankind at large how
do we start to address to mitigate and
to adapt with control theory uh based on
the Earth's changing climate
and ensuring the quality of life this is
again something that affects essentially
All Humans is health and well-being this
is one of the goals across the entire
Globe across every age group is having a
healthy quality life and how can again
control theory help with both you know
medical devices but also things like
sensing and diagnosis prediction
intervention and also the fair and
equitable distribution of medical
resources really really important
societal level challenge
smart infrastructure systems this is
really really essential if we think
about Transportation energy food you
know you name it infrastructure systems
are becoming instrumented electrified
Communications networks are tying these
together so what is uh what is that
going to mean for us what are the
challenges how do we how do we work
towards that and live you know with
these smart infrastructure systems
uh the sharing economy I think this is
super interesting this is something I
hadn't really thought of until I read
this uh this roadmap is things like uber
and Lyft and Airbnb when you have
resources that different people kind of
share almost like a time share
how do you develop the control
strategies for making sure again that
there is Equitable access that things
work together that you have enough
resources lots of interesting control
theory challenges in the sharing economy
I learned a lot reading that section
resilience is another big issue so when
you have uh you know large-scale Global
issues like climate change like
political instabilities and you know War
there is the necessity to have your
societal scale infrastructure have a
basic resiliency we want to have
tolerance to faults and issues that
arise in our in our system in our
societal scale systems and so resilience
is something that again control theory
can really uh help address things like
robustness and distributed resources
network security things like that
uh and there's actually two really cool
appendices to this fantastic chapter
that I like a lot one is about pandemics
uh how we model and control so very
topical with uh covet 19. again it's
related to health care and ensuring the
quality of life but this is kind of a
deeper dive into pandemics and similarly
a deeper dive into neuro engineering
which is a field of tremendous potential
and impact and development that's being
driven by by control theory okay super
exciting chapter I'm just going to give
you a very very very high level sneak
peek of some of the things you know in
here so I'm going to pick and choose
some of the ones I think are interesting
and maybe some of the ones you know I
might know a little teeny bit about
again read this yourself download this
you know see if there are some of these
that you want to get working on that you
want to start applying your trade and
your control theory expertise to
actually start addressing
so climate change is one that's kind of
easy to wrap our heads around in terms
of this is a societal scale challenge
this is something that is uh you know is
and will be increasingly affecting all
of us and this is something that we need
to address with the best sharpest tools
we have available as humans so clearly
uh some of the issues related to climate
change are modeling how do you model how
a system a complex multi-scale
multi-physics dynamical system evolves
in the future how do you predict and
estimate how do you bound and manage
your uncertainty of those those
estimates those are very closely related
to control theory problems and similarly
once you have those models and estimates
how do you how do you place Sensors how
do you use your sensor Network to better
inform those models and ultimately how
do we actually intervene this is really
where control theory comes in how do we
actuate how do we intervene in this
system to mitigate the effects of
climate change to actually you know
bring the system into some kind of
regulatory balance that you know is good
for for life on Earth and similarly for
some cases where we can't mitigate the
changes how do we adapt as a society how
do we adapt our infrastructure how do we
adapt our energy
systems and and things like that our
food and agriculture so these are
mitigation and adaptation strategies
driven by control
because of this societal scale challenge
of climate change okay so that's the
kind of thing that this this roadmap is
really looking at is what are the huge
challenges and what are some of the ways
that we need to use control theory to
address these
um I think there's some really cool
diagrams and data in this roadmap that I
found pretty useful so this is you know
Global greenhouse gas emissions by
sector in the year 2016 and this kind of
information is really helpful when we as
Engineers are trying to solve a problem
you have to be able to kind of
quantitatively break the problem down
and see where do you actually Focus your
energy as a control theorist so you know
this gives you some idea of where you
might want to kind of start zooming in
and focusing and understanding uh at
finer resolution
and there's a lot of cool
recommendations one of the things I
really like about this roadmap is uh you
know there is an executive summary for
every chapter and every section there
are recommendations for practitioners
for funding agencies there are you know
short-term medium-term and long-term
opportunities and so I think this is a
very thoughtful and very well organized
uh kind of resource to get people
thinking on the same page you might not
agree with every single thing in here I
don't know that anyone is going to
um but it's it's so well organized that
we know exactly where we can have
discussions and where we can focus our
energy and kind of start to to do more
research and and activities
okay so that was climate change just one
you know section in this massive chapter
another one I think is super important
is uh kind of the health care and you
know biotechnology and you know
neurotechnology things like that so some
of the applications that I thought were
really interesting was
um you know the rise of the internet of
things especially in medicine is going
to be a huge deal so I took off my you
know Smart Watch which measures my you
know heart rate how I sleep all of my
Biometrics but increasingly we're going
to have this kind of medical internet of
things that's going to have this immense
amount of data that can be used so how
is that going to affect things
um things like automated insulin
delivery or automated anesthesiology or
anesthetics these are going to be game
changers in the medical industry and for
increasing quality of life and health
care outcomes for you know hopefully
Millions if not billions of people
worldwide
cardiac assist devices right so you know
things that actually help people's
hearts stay healthy uh you know in lots
of different scenarios
diabetes again insulin I think is a
major major wannabe so there's so many
applications in the healthcare
realm and one of the things I thought
was really cool about this particular
roadmap is there seems to be a thread
going throughout about not just solving
these problems for a few but how do we
solve these problems in a way that is
Equitable and fair and distributed so
that everybody gets to benefit from
these advances I think that's a really
really cool perspective and something I
I liked a lot that I didn't necessarily
expect coming into reading this but I I
took away and I liked a lot
um you know the neural engineering is
another huge field that I think it's
it's not just super cool because it's
sci-fi you know high tech implants and
brain stimulation and things like that
but this can have real actual impact in
improving quality of life so there are
deep brain stimulation devices right now
that use closed-loop feedback control
for example to control Parkinson's or
extreme cases of obsessive-compulsive
disorder and so these are really cool
technologies that in extreme cases are
helping people regain basic regulatory
functions uh in their body and this is
something I wanted to to kind of convey
after reading this is
when you think about health care and
human health our bodies are essentially
a control system our climate is a
control system and our bodies are a
control system and so if you really
think about it uh control theory can
help us bring those systems back into
regulation back into good you know
healthy working order when they start to
go out of regular of bounds or when when
our systems stop being able to regulate
themselves naturally and so I think
that's a really cool perspective in kind
of climate and in health is that
feedback control it's inherent to those
systems naturally but we as humans can
augment those control systems and get
even better outcomes
okay so those are just a number of the
things that you're going to read about
in this chapter I think it's super super
cool again these are Grand Challenge
problems these are problems that affect
you know billions of people they are
trillions of dollar problems they have
huge impact in our future in the future
of Our Lives of our children so really
exciting and this should get us
motivated and inspired to actually start
you know applying the great work we're
doing in control theory to help make a
difference here all right thank you